[Music]
few actors have been lucky enough to
feature in a universally acclaimed movie
and fewer still have appeared in many
but it does happen from major movie
stars to little-known character
performers
these are the actors who have the most
movies with a 100
score on rotten tomatoes in 1959 alec
guinness was awarded a knighthood by
elizabeth ii for his contribution to the
field of arts
just in case his academy award his bafta
his star on the hollywood walk of fame
and his nine perfect movies on rotten
tomatoes weren't testament enough to his
talent
like many other esteemed actors alec
guinness enjoyed working with one
particular director
the british thespian was a preferred
collaborator for the acclaimed director
david lean
often appearing in his legendary screen
adaptations of charles dickens films
such as
great expectations and oliver twist both
of these films are among guinness 100
movies which also includes two of the
darkest comedies
ever made the ladykillers and kind
hearts and coronaes
of course guinness will forever be
remembered as obi-wan kenobi in george
lucas's original star wars trilogy
but that movie isn't one of the nine
boasting an impressive yet
imperfect 92 percent on rotten tomatoes
total i have a feeling we're not in
kansas anymore
judy garland may well be one of the most
famous actresses of
all time though she's perhaps best known
as dorthy in 1939's the wizard of oz
which sits at 98 on rotten tomatoes
garland has appeared in a total of nine
films with a perfect score
including the christmas classic meet me
in st louis and
other beloved musicals such as
summerstalk and till the clouds roll by
garland is yet another critically
renowned star who took on a new name
during her youth
in this case from frances ethel gum
while performing with her siblings as
the singing gum sisters
a fellow performer suggested they
changed the name the gum sisters became
the garland sisters and judy chose her
new first name based on inspiration from
a hoagie carmichael song
unfortunately this was just the first of
many demands
showbiz would come to place on garland
in the end garland was overcome by the
pressures of the industry the abusive
nature of the people she worked with
and the substance abuse that followed
she died of an accidental overdose in
1969.
having being forced to fend for herself
at a very young age it makes sense that
barbara stanwick would be best known for
playing complex and independent women on
screen
she began working at just 13 years old
first as a chorus girl then
a nightclub dancer and finally with
touring companies
she then landed her first broadway play
in 1926 with
the noose in which she played the role
of a cabaret dancer
her leading role in the 1927 run of
burlesque earned stanwick her first
movie offers marking the beginning of a
long career in hollywood
one that included such films as the lady
eve which is just one of her nine
films with a 100 rating on rotten
tomatoes stanwick was one of the most
versatile adaptable actresses in the
history of cinema
she even changed her name at the alleged
behest of a producer on the noose
having been born ruby catherine stevens
because she was known for that
versatility
rather than the movie star glamour that
was the typical of female leads at the
time
she was often passed over for actresses
like betty davis or jean arthur
but none of those stars ever appeared in
more
truly great movies than this
self-sufficient queen of stage and
scream
born samuel jones in 1898 the man later
known as wallace ford ran away from an
abusive home and joined a vaudeville
troop traveling through canada
as a teenager he journeyed south by
train hopping to the us
in search of a better life with his
friend who was actually named wallace
ford
tragically ford was run over by a
locomotive and jones then took the name
of his dead friend as tribute
and what a tribute it was from theater
troops to broadway to hollywood
ford made a home in the entertainment
industry just as he made a home in
america
he became known as a tough but friendly
and quick-witted comic character
who starred in over 150 tv series and
films
nine of which were 100 percent loved by
critics
these included alfred hitchcock's shadow
of a doubt and
the surprisingly dark jimmy stewart
western
the man from laramie gary cooper's
characters were often soft-spoken and
stoic
yet always heroic this unique persona
led the man born as frank james cooper
to become a much
loved star in the entertainment industry
with his iconic drawl
and imposing height cooper was the
perfect pick for the western genre
so it should come as no surprise that
titles like the westerner
the virginian and the plainsman are all
riding tall in the 100
rotten tomatoes saddle he also starred
in war films such as beaujest
and comedies like ball of fire but if
you really want to understand cooper's
charm
you have to look outside his 100 lineup
and focus
on 1941's meet john doe in a roundabout
way
this movie says the most about the types
of characters cooper portrayed
rather than the elite hollywood actor
whose star power leaked into every role
audiences got to know cooper as the
everyman the literal
john doe who reflected the dreams and
aspirations of the everyday average
american
it makes sense that humphrey bogart be
closely associated with the notion of
hollywood perfection
considering he's the iconic face of the
1942 film so frequently cited as the
epitome of
good cinema casablanca in fact renowned
critic roger ebert once suggested
casablanca appears on more best films of
all time lists than
any other movie surprisingly enough
however casablanca scores
99 on rod tomatoes meaning it doesn't
quite make it into bogart's 100 club
still he has an impressive 11 perfect
scoring movies to make up for it
one of those films 1941's the maltese
falcon
catapulted bogart to a whole new level
of success
having slowly worked his way through b
movies and played supporting roles in
bigger flicks
bogart was suddenly a leading man and
he'd soon become known as one of the
all-time greats
it's interesting to note however that he
had an exactly equal number of 100
rated films before and after the maltese
falcon
a testament to the fact that he'd always
been an asset to the productions in
which he featured
whether he was the leading man or not is
looking at you kid
funnily enough the legendary actor see
aubrey smith started out as a cricketer
and the sportsmanlike conduct of the
game easily translated to the
gentlemanly characters he'd become
known for in hollywood smith appeared in
11 perfect scoring movies during his
career
such as the four feathers and and then
there were none
and in the majority of them he portrayed
either an aristocrat or a military
officer
indeed it seems like smith never quite
forgot his roots
even after arriving in california he
insisted that his english colleagues all
join the hollywood cricket club
and make a point to show up and play too
in addition to being renowned for the
roles he played
smith was also famous for his facial
hair which included a set of bushy
eyebrows and an impressive handlebar
mustache
along with his cricket obsession that
impressive stash
fed back into the persona of the
hollywood gentleman and sure maybe that
meant smith was a little typecast but it
clearly served him well
during his 34-year career from his early
beginnings at the omaha community
playhouse
henry fonda rose to great prominence in
the entertainment industry
and eventually played in 11 films that
received 100
approval ratings from critics on rotten
tomatoes he appeared in a number of
productions now regarded as classics
such as the lady eve and the iconic
courtroom thriller 12 angry men
his working relationship with john ford
also produced a good few films with 100
ratings including the grapes of wrath
young mr lincoln and my darling
clementine
fonda's range was exceptionally wide not
just in terms of acting ability but in
the projects he featured in too
in fact he's the only actor with a
number of 100
films in the double digits who also
appeared in a film with a
zero percent approval rating on rotten
tomatoes the much maligned
1977 movie tentacles but fonda's legacy
is carried by his family as well as his
films
he's the father of decorated actress and
activist jane fonda
as well as actor and director peter
fonda his rotten tomatoes profile
describes him as having a
benign paternal presence and despite
being somewhat distant as an actual
father
he clearly instilled a genuine love of
acting into his children
audiences saw the actor and military
officer james stewart as the embodiment
of the ideal american
something of a nebulous accolade today
but back then
it made him one of the most popular
movie stars around he was clearly a hit
with the critics too
having appeared in a dozen pictures that
are currently 100
favorably reviewed the moral rectitude
of his early roles may have been part of
what made the moral obscurity of his
later roles
all the more striking though they aren't
counted among his perfect scoring pieces
stewart starred in a number of legendary
hitchcock films
often as a far shadier character than
those he was better known for playing
that's also true for the naked spur a
100
scoring western that found stewart
playing a bounty hunter with a serious
dark side
this trend continued with movies such as
the man from laramie
and winchester 73 which cemented
stewart's reputation
as one of the most versatile and popular
actors of his era
one of the most recognizable names in
cinema history also boasts a whopping 12
movies with a 100
ron tomato score marion robert morrison
known professionally by his screen name
john wayne
is almost synonymous with the american
western and he was a surefire box office
hit
for many decades none of this might ever
have happened however if marion robert
morrison the football player hadn't
suffered a career-ending injury
with his sporting dreams dashed morrison
turned to hollywood for his shot at
greatness
his very first leading role was of
course in western
1930s the big trail but the picture
which made him famous
didn't arrive until nine years later
john ford's 1939 movie stagecoach
featured wayne in the role of the ringo
kid and subsequently made him a
household name
fittingly both of these films have
earned 100 approval ratings on rotten
tomatoes along with other such classics
as rio bravo
red river and el dorado ward bond has
the most 100 scoring movies of any actor
in history
which appears to be one of the great
benefits of being a character actor
bond didn't often play the lead in his
films but his status as an indispensable
supporting character
led to the record breath of his career
in universally beloved films
as a result bond has played in a
stunning
15 films with 100 on rotten tomatoes
including the grapes of wrath the
maltese falcon
and young mr lincoln in particular he
starred in almost
two dozen movies alongside his former
football teammate john wayne
and often worked with preferred
collaborators such as john ford and
frank capra
on top of that he has appeared in a
number of all-time classics with
slightly less than perfect scores such
as it's a wonderful life
and gone with the wind so while ward
bond may not have been the most famous
actor to have worked in hollywood
it's unlikely anyone will ever quite
manage to match his
incredible achievement check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one